plot massy santé sécurité économie à un
mois du premier tour de la
présidentielle ont fait le bilan des
plus et des moins sur tous les sujets
en france le pays qui est manuel macron
a voulu transformer en start up nation
le président peut se gargariser d'avoir
atteint avec trois ans d'avancé objectif
de 2025 puisque la france compte déjà 26
licorne à savoir des start up française
valorisée à plus d'un milliard de
dollars et fort de ces résultats la
macro ni peut désormais regarder vers
l'avenir et revoir ses objectifs à la
hausse comme pourquoi pas réussir à
faire entrer des start up française dans
le cac 40 d'ici 2025
quand on regarde dans le détail
cependant les secteurs sur lesquels
opère ces startups ne sont pas si
diversifiés que sa finance e-commerce
logiciel on reste beaucoup dans le
dématérialisé seule une de ces startups
exo tech est présente dans le secteur
industriel emmanuel macron veut
développer à la fois les start up et
l'industrie et a proposé un ambitieux
plan d'investissement de 30 milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans baptisé france 2030
si on veut construire la france de 2030
on doit reconquérir de la part
industrielle on doit rénover dans et par
l'industrie et donc décidé de multiplier
des financement de start-up industriels
mais sur le plan industriel la france
reste fragilisé un des derniers dossiers
en date la liquidation prononcée en
novembre de l'asm un sous traitant de
renault dans l'aveyron sur place les
syndicalistes accusent le gouvernement
le gouvernement actionnaire à hauteur de
15% de renault nous a promis qu'il
allait faire pression sur le
constructeur pour faciliter la reprise
en réalité rien n'a été fait et les
pièces que nous fabriquons ici sont
désormais produite en espagne et en
roumanie
alstom alcatel lucent world poule le nom
d' emmanuel macron à la fois en tant que
ministre d'économie sous françois
hollande que de président reste attaché
à un certain nombre de dossiers
controversés des failles dans lesquels
ne manqueront pas de s'engouffrer les
prétendants à sa succession
au cours des débats pour la
présidentielle